hey everyone how's it going I'm ash
Crossin AVENGERS endgame is out now this
is your biggest spoiler warning I'm
gonna put how many spoiler graphics can
I put on screen there we go
there's a million there's a million
there you go we are gonna be talking
about the biggest moments the biggest
deaths the unanswered question so if you
haven't seen it
just go away just go away and come back
and also what are you doing spit out
let's go joining me today is hector
navarro host of el radiation hi i'm so
happy to be here so happy to have you
and scott magic critic
whoo one of my favs e's are all my face
let's just jump right into it
expectation versus reality mmm where did
avengers endgame stack up for you you go
first
first it exceeded my expectations
because after last year's pretty epic
and then ending on a down note infinity
war and then the two movies in between
em and the wasp and Captain Marvel which
would really like palate cleansers but
they weren't the big show I let myself I
force myself rather to not speculate to
not try and think about theorizing how
they're gonna bring everybody back how
they're gonna defeat Thanos well I
didn't want to do that I didn't want to
tap into my comic book knowledge I was
just trying to avoid it at all costs
what I didn't expect was for Avengers
end game to end up being this
meta-narrative this thank you to the
fans reflection on the entire franchise
it made me pause and think about my life
where I was 11 years ago in my early
twenties when these movies started and a
bunch of people were in their teens and
they've grown up with this thing yeah
right it made me think about my own
loved ones and made me really give pause
and and and and just think about my own
life and that I did not expect so in
that way it absolutely exceeded my
expectations because it was epic it was
bombastic it was a big superhero comic
book movie they're very good at making
them they're 22 movies in they're pretty
good at it but it's the other stuff that
I really didn't expect those those gut
punches of emotions yeah and I was in
tears and then so yeah
I completely agree this movie guest did
exceed my expectations over and over
again I went to this movie with a lot of
hopes because I feel like what Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios he
has been the brainchild of this entire
MCU that we've had these last 11 years
starting with the first Ironman at the
very end of the film that bonus scene
when Sam Jackson
Nick Fury shows up to bring Tony Stark
into the Avengers initiative and here we
are 22 movies later we've had some
really really great movies like Thor
Ragnarok which I know you love love
Captain America Winter Soldier in which
up to this point was my favorite but
here you have a film that exceeds all
those expectations because of the many
emotional moments because of how poetic
this movie is this movie is poetic it
gets very existential when you see how
much these Avengers lose themselves when
they lose the Avengers right it's so
bold and ambitious and smart and it's
and that the other thing I didn't expect
I mean this movie it's not predictable
at all like I did not know where it was
gonna go I feel like I kind of predicted
things that would happen but like the
execution was like absolutely not what I
did not think here we go spoilers are
happening
Santos getting killed off in like 20
minutes were awesome but they awesome
right and after that Ash when it says
five yep years later now this is a
device that we've seen in the reimagined
Battlestar Galactica and we've seen it
in Los where they flash-forward a number
of years and it's when it's done like
this it really works because everybody
in the audience what whoa like they
really went there and you see this guy
that's like kind of just like a weak
dude he like destroyed the stones he's
in a freaking t-shirt he's gardening
like he's just not a threat in this like
now what do I do
yeah what are they gonna do for the rest
of the night I love that it was not
obvious I love that the screen writers
specifically purposefully tried to write
these characters in this situation where
was not an easy undo now Christopher
Markus and Stephen get Billy who wrote
the screenplay and they have Joe Russo
and Anthony Russo so now this is their
fourth collaboration together after
Captain America Winter Soldier Captain
America Civil War Avengers infinity war
and now Avengers ain't games so they all
know how to work really really well
together
and on top of everything this is a movie
that three hours and one minute it flew
by goes my like that and you know what
the ratio of action to running time is
actually very very low there's not a lot
of action in endgame especially compared
to infinity war which was like
wall-to-wall action yes
but the emotional moments like when Tony
Eric sees his father I mean there are so
many great emotional moments as d-v
seeing Peggy yeah thora seeing his mom
that is a man I love because I just want
to talk about I know we're talking about
the cameos in a moment but one of the
criticisms of a lot of these movies are
when you look back on him you go you
know what Rene Russo didn't do enough
Thor the dark world it wasn't enough for
me and in this movie went and made Thor
the dark world an essential entry in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that's amazing
when I started working here it was the
first movie I start to finish so I was
like I love Thor
let's talk about some of those stand up
standout moments what was your number
one we don't say all right this is a
this is gonna be a real surface level
easy one for me not only have I been
invested in this movie franchise since
2008 but I have been a Marvel Comics and
superhero comic book reader since I as
long as I can remember being alive since
I was five years old so I have been
waiting 30 years of life to hear
Avengers Assemble and that moment which
is preceded by a fantastic MCU original
on your left which is another moment
that made me almost tear up to hear Sam
come back cap it's me it's Sam on your
left and then the ring start to appear
and then everyone show up that was
something that I I mean this this
franchise continually delivers on things
that I never thought would be imaginable
from a comic book fan standpoint and now
we're here and there was everyone in the
universe fighting all of the bad guys in
the most epic it challenges Lord of the
Rings in terms of level of epicness
I have to go Avengers Assemble that's
mice that's my number one pursuit as he
said that though I was like well Tony
says I am Iron Man I'm like that was my
moment really because I feel like the
even though we've had three standalone
Iron Man films even though Robert Downey
jr. as Iron Man he's been in the
Avengers films he was in Captain America
Civil War he was in spider-man
homecoming and by the way he was
fantastic and spider-man home oh yeah
yeah paternal relationship he has with
Tom Hollands Peter Parker is really
really great and led to this great
emotional payoff in event
infinity war when peter parker's
disappears and when he comes back and he
hugs him it was really really sweet but
the MCU started it started with Iron Man
and it ends with Iron Man I felt very
very emotional
bring on the fields when when Pepper
Potts went a pouch of those over and
says you can rest now I felt like I
didn't expect that at all
I mean you know what the other thing
that really struck out at me here is the
score the score on this movie by the
great Alan Silvestri amazing he crushed
it I mean this is like John Williams
yeah level gorgeous for and it's it's
it's beautiful
the like Gwyneth Paltrow just making me
weep openly in the field I was like
Gwyneth Paltrow I'm gonna crack as a
Gwyneth Paltrow
it was it was that it was Tom Holland
Spidey and it was Don Cheadle's roadie
those three characters are so pivotal to
Stark and they were there and they were
letting him know you can rest and I'm
sorry and it was it was a beautiful
moment and it did again it made me just
reflect on all franchise the other thing
here is just crucial is that Tony Stark
got to meet his father okay and he says
you know I they're talking and Tony
Stark says you know I used to think my
father was really mean but now when I
look back I just remember the good
things and then you know his father is
asking him about oh how do you like
being a father he says he'll you know
figure it out along the way it was like
it's so many emotional moments so here's
the crucial thing yeah it did not feel
contrived like everything about this
movie earned all of it yeah all of it
was it was like a fanservice done right
yes exactly that's a perfect way to put
it ash because you know when you watch
movies especially when we watch movies
like this and we get the fanservice we
feel like we're getting the fanservice
for example when we see Yoda in the last
Jedi the Star Wars movie yeah that felt
like fanservice and a felt forced it
didn't work there was nothing about
nothing about this movie felt forced at
all everything was earned not just for
this film but because of everything that
preceded it the brilliance and yes I am
going to use that word on a
Marvel comic book movie the brilliance
of endgame is that not only ties the
film together not only does a tie the
MCU together but it folds back onto
itself and the process by going back to
Avengers the first Avengers movie let's
go back to Thor 2 by going back to
guardians of the galaxy like like who
knew that the movie was gonna do that
like watching I went back and watched
Winter Soldier the other day and there's
the moment where he meets up with old
Peggy and they're like talking and she
says like you can't go back and I'm just
like there's so many lines throughout
that are now so much more important they
have a completely different way to them
now
you think you do want to go back and I'm
sure a lot of us will go back and
re-watch the watch all the movies in the
MCU like I mean I never thought I would
say this but I can't wait to watch Thor
- I know yeah I know I'm like I need to
watch I need to re-watch age of Ultron
which is like a thing I never thought I
would say in my life and here we are um
for me you know Peggy and cap have
always been endgame and like it's kind
of like a running thing in this office
that we're like Peggy and cat forever
never thought yeah they would ever
somehow get back together yeah yet here
we are sorry Sharon Carter yeah Peggy
and cat for life I think that that's
really again as a comic book fan Peggy
and Steve were not as a powerful
romantic fixture in Marvel Comics as
Sharon and Steve were and Sharon and
Steve sort of become the OTP or as one
true pairs the kids would call it but
these movies have taken off in such a
way and they become such a cultural
phenomenon that like Hayley Atwell Peggy
absolutely hit with audiences and I feel
like that influenced the ultimate
direction they're gonna go into and the
fact that you thought that never in a
million years would they end up together
I feel like it does a couple of things
it's another aspect of the brilliance of
endgame and it provides something to
superhero franchises that I don't think
have ever really had it outside of maybe
the Christopher Nolan Dark Knight
trilogy that's kind of an isolated
incident and that is finality we just
assumed Robert Downey jr. would play
Iron Man forever we just assumed Chris
Evans was gonna play Captain America
Steve Rogers until either his contract
is up but then they write up another
contract he'd cameo again like we just
shake up the truck yeah do that but but
the fact that those two characters have
had these endings and I think truly both
of them are
even though they're also kind of tragic
it means that we're gonna look back on
the rest of the franchise and go we only
had three Iron Man movies now it might
seem like a lot compared to other
characters and other franchises and
other movies but in terms of comic-book
storytelling comic book readers are very
used to these characters staying the
same age for decades right well you know
what's interesting is that he was only
in three stand alone i right fellas but
he was yeah but but when you look at
Captain America Civil War and the
Avengers films an end game infinity war
yeah it the gravity always seems to
swirl around Robb or things what it's
about yeah you know and even even
throwing that last sign off and the
ending credits to end game which did
feel very much like Star Trek 60
undiscovered but you know what is he oh
yeah it did it was it was the goodbye
now
it's funny you say that you know we felt
like Iron Man was gonna be played by
Robert dad forever forever or a same
thing with Chris Evans his cap mm-hmm
but not really I mean really they can't
exactly yeah it's because they aged like
regular humans because they're real-life
human beings console characters stay the
same age right Iron Man has been like
3540 since 1963 all right but just a
geek out for a second yeah ashen and
Hector's right here so you have
spider-man which over the last let's see
17 years now since May of 2002 is now
been played by three actors live-action
on screen this is not including the
brilliant oscar-winning film
spider-verse rate which was should have
been nominated for Best Picture but but
so they can keep recasting Peter Parker
right who in their right mind would ever
even think about playing Tony Stark
yeah or or yeah we're good Steve Rogers
yeah you cannot it's like trying to
recast Indiana Jones it's only Harrison
Ford I'd rather see him all than the
credit right this this so the acting in
this movie is so strong it's so strong
like so what if you think Robert Downey
jr. can get a Best Actor nomination do I
think that he is worthy okay I agree the
thing here it's only you know you still
got a whole lot of time before they even
roll out these Oscar contenders they do
what the end of the year sure so I'm not
gonna say I'm calling it now or it's
luck I'm not doing this over I'll do it
it's a lock he's gonna win he's gonna be
nominated with think that he is he
worthy of be nominated
yeah and on that note it's the film
Avengers an endgame worthy of being
nominated for Best Picture and Best
Director
absolutely and is it worthy of winning
do I think it's worthy of winning
because of the way it seamlessly
brilliantly wraps up this whole and see
you and because of the fields that you
get because of how bold and ambitious
actually is and how smart it is and how
well acted it is the scope of the film
this movie does for the MCU where Return
of the King did Ford Lord of the Rings
and that was just exactly so is it
worthy of winning it's a worthy film to
win but I'm again I'm not okay let's
move on let's talk about the biggest
deaths in the movie we talked a lot
about Tony Stark
r.i.p he got a funeral he got a send-off
you know who did not get a funeral I
know there's a lot of movie in this
movie been thrown into a lake she did
she did get that you know because that's
what I love about that moment is that
when all the characters go off into
their time-travel stuff and then Paul
Rudd is sent back to the present and we
got some characters I have to go to 1970
and then we have some characters
returning from
Morag and and and all that other stuff
it all happens instantaneously and
jeremy renner hawkeye he comes back
without Black Widow and that scene I
think leads directly to that let's go
throw a bench we're so upset and that
leads directly to let's just put it on
let's just snap it like it's so quick
and happened so quickly and that's just
enough time for 2014 nebula to mosey on
over to that device bring fan house over
and then we get the big show what did
you think of that because I felt like
Black Widow got shortchanged in this
game
and I feel like her death scene like
when you're thinking about the deaths in
this movie the descend offs in this film
including cap yeah I had to think for a
second wait a minute what happened to
Black Widow oh that's right like it took
me a second because I just felt like she
deserved better the character deserved
better
I know we're not gonna see the last of
our she's getting her own spin like that
opens that whole can of worms it's like
when is that show taking place yeah but
her like actual death scene like when
they get to form here and you just have
that moment where you realize oh wait
one of them has to go down mm-hmm
did you think was gonna be Hawkeye eye
when he went to run I was like it's
gonna be him yeah but in my mind I hate
saying this but it's like I wanted it to
be her because I was like I'm not that
invested in the Marvel movies have been
making you think Hawkeye is gonna die
cuz he's just a guy with a bow and arrow
since 2012 they played with it in 2015
and it was Quicksilver who ended up
dying out of any of the Avengers
characters we didn't see that coming and
that moment that scene and on Vermeer I
think that Scarlett Johansson and Jeremy
Renner are acting their asses off yes
she she because I was so invested in the
story the first go-around and because it
did kind of happen so quickly yes time I
saw the film I wasn't as emotional the
second time I saw it when I knew what
was gonna happen and I was really
looking at them acting with each other
and their relationship and the way that
everything went down and the lines that
they were saying to each other the fact
that Natasha was saying everything in my
life has led up to this moment I've been
trying to get the red out of my ledger
at this very moment and in hot guys
going I've killed people I'm not working
she goes you didn't judge me when you
were sent to kill me and said you
recruited me into shield into the
American side into the good guys side
and I'm not gonna judge you
you good you're worthy just as I'm
worthy I had my family it was the
Avengers I'm doing this for them that
you have your family and I thought it
was beautifully executed now is it a
shame that the like predominant you know
female Avenger was the one to die
absolutely but for me I think that the
funerals aside they served that
character in a sort of same way that
they serve Tony Stark but I am thankful
that we're going to get more of her and
I'm really really thankful that we got
that moment at the end of the film with
essentially the a forced lineup of all
the female characters in a way that the
movie was like I apologize
but it was a rousing moment like
everybody would go cheer everybody was
cheering yeah I agree you know it's like
and it was just like a moment versus
significant like if people are upset
that it's not logical that those certain
characters would be on that battlefield
fighting Thanos at that exact same time
we're watching a movie with fan no it's
like it's like it's all make them ups
like it's all such a green screen you
know computer graphic make them ups but
to me that moment represented a promise
in the same way I tie it to when Steve
gave Sam the shield and those characters
and Sam Wilson just by their very
existence are inherently political
characters because they're women and
it's a black guy and if those statements
were powerful and I love that biggest
stuff so we got we got Black Widow we
got Tony we have like some like past
nebula a kind of confusing thing but I
think one thing that I was hoping would
maybe happen but didn't is like anybody
who has pre snapped Deadwood there--it
they're gone you're talking vision
you're talking yeah I'm using more by
the way baby could not even be bothered
they're gone
yes yes and that's this is another thing
I love about the film because after
infinity working out many many cynical
movie audiences we're like oh well
they're just gonna get not a matter
they're none of it matters they're just
gonna undo it and I was holding out hope
and going you know maybe wait maybe
because there's been a there's been a
handful of fake out deaths in the MCU
Nick Fury was thought to have died in
Winter Soldier but then he was alive in
that same movie Loki at the end of Thor
then he comes back and then Loki during
Thor the dark world but then nope he's
actually Odin he's fine so I understand
people being upset with that or even
Groot right and then we still get a teen
group yeah but then that have to be
explained James Gunn's saying no no the
original Groot is dead this new group
does not have those memories this isn't
it's like his child that's like a new
character there are more dead characters
in the MCU I feel like then there are
alive but there's so many there's mentor
characters there's you don't I mean
there's there's so many different
pivotal roles I'm thinking about the
ancient one Tilda Swinton hmm ho yinsen
from the first Iron Man film who was
Shaun toub the fantastic Stanley Tucci
from Captain America the First Avenger
and all of those characters because they
all you know aged up and died because
they're from World War two but there are
oh there are almost as many like
deceased characters as there are live
ones and I am so so happy that the movie
said we can't just you know undo and
bring back vision yakamora or all of
those other characters that made
sacrifices that were meaningful so
that's great the thing is like so when
you get to the part where in when Scott
Lang comes out of there whatever and
he's you know five years into the future
with everybody else and then they talk
about time travel I went oh I'm an time
travel it's such a cop-out it like I
kind of felt for a moment mm-hmm that it
was a compound yeah and then they drew
like attention to it they sort of make
fun of it by bringing up Star Trek back
to the future but the way it played out
yes was brilliant yeah it played out was
great they did just go back in time they
went back again this is what I mean
about it falling back onto its own
legacy and and recreated scenes like you
know everyone was saying last fall at
Telluride that Robert referenced last
movie yeah highest-grossing movie of all
time now I think I have answers are
these how many of these are new and how
many of these are just like deleted
scene there's no way now that was a
movie when they first go back to 2012
yeah during the first Avengers yeah and
you see that sort of like shot where
it's there the circle around yes that
that was pulled from the original film
yeah but everything else about that yeah
was reshot and by the way Natalie
Portman did not reshoot this movie I she
did she was at the premiere I just feel
like she was a show her when they show
her in that shot where she's like
talking and that's yeah
you're like that's a deleted scene
that's her yeah and then they close up
when she's on the bed she's on the bed
well like with Redford when they when
they're showing represent give me the
briefcase and everything I thought for a
moment that that was like you know they
were going back to a scene from Captain
America Winter Soldier but I watched a
Winter Soldier over the weekend yeah
that's a lot like FX or something and
Robert Redford's hair was a lot shorter
in the moon
so he well it was a lot longer in
Avengers and game so listen you you have
all these people sort of coming out of
the woodwork to do really really short
brief cameos and they're great my one of
my favorite ones was when they were in
the elevator yeah and Frank Grillo and
like fan that was a big point of
contention for comic nerds a couple
years ago when the character of Captain
America in a comic said hail Hydra huge
controversy people did not like that
I loved how this film made that little
comic book moment like amazing and
people cheered when he said it people
applauded so good Hector yes we have to
talk about the scene that made everybody
go ape are you my Captain America's ass
my cat vs cat okay yeah absolutely
fun everybody you know it's just went
crazy and you know what the important
thing is the scene made sense it was
another scene a fanservice that worked
it worked as a plot point for the
cavalry to move the story forward gonna
be that easy for these characters to go
back to 2012 they get the scepter but oh
nope Loki's got the tesseract he's out
so now what you have to do it's the
Avengers
whatever it takes exactly I love that
literal Ness yes one where does the MCU
go from here yeah did this seem like
watching it again I was like oh this is
like a lot of like Disney Plus setup Oh
the tesseract and he goes off into like
us like presumably an alternate timeline
slash TV show right yes Sam gets the
shield I don't know what you're thinking
about vision yeah at the end that moment
with with Jeremy Renner which was great
because they have their characters have
a sort of a history in the heck of a lot
of kids yeah like a lot of kids well
like we done grown up Cassie laughs yeah
yeah Ian could be something someday this
is what's exciting this is similar to
spider
- the spider-verse anyone can wear the
mask and the message of that film as
well as this message about about picking
up the mantle and about who's worthy of
being these famous characters and as a
comic book fan and as a dude who happens
to be brown I have been I have been
thinking about this and wanting it and
and and it's something that's very very
important to me which is fair and
accurate representation and just by the
nature of where these stories originated
from they were in the Silver Age of
comics that was the 60s or earlier there
were different priorities in terms of
how we represented the world around us
you know things back then in the 60s
things like black panther that character
was groundbreaking you know that those
kinds of things were not often they were
the exceptions to the rule so comic
books have attempted to and their
decades-long history provide us with new
characters that better reflect the world
around us Miles Morales you know female
versions of Ironman riri Williams a
black 15 year old MIT you know woman who
creates her own Ironman suit you had an
Asian Hulk with Amadeus Cho totally
awesome Hulk for a little bit Natalie
Portman's character Jane Foster picked
up the hammer and she was Thor for years
she was the Mighty Thor
don't forget beta ray bill better a bill
who was a horse too but also brown
people the main thing is that with these
fantastic characters including Miles
Morales they show up they make these big
splashes spider-gwen is another great
example but often times are relegated to
their own universe it doesn't
necessarily count you still have the
regular sort of character the original
character comes back because these comic
book characters aren't allowed to age
and the thing that's so exciting about
the MCU is it's decided we're not gonna
recast Tony Stark we're not gonna recast
Steve Rogers just to have those
characters around we have legacy we can
forward we have we have to move forth
this one map say in the movie or Steve
Rogers he says when he's when he's in
that therapy session with Joe Russo by
the way yeah I thanks little cameo and
he's talking about letting go yeah so
about letting go and moving forward
growing and moving on yeah I think that
was a little bit of a message you know
for people who's hanging on and you know
the MCU isn't over it's just going to
grow and evolve yeah there's one more
thing I want to talk about the
post-credit mid-credits scene
/ there isn't one did you well there was
there was something interesting though
because at the end there's like a
clinking sound yeah how did you guys
interpret that yeah here's the
interesting thing about the the
post-credits what the MCU has done
starting with the first Ironman was was
start the anticipation what is the post
credit scene going to be in some cases
some of these MCU movies have had to one
after the main credits and the one after
the very garden where's your Guardians -
so now we but we're at this point where
we can't wait to see what the bonus
credit scene is going to be yeah and
that was definitely the case watching
Avengers Anki oh my god what's going to
be are they going to have one the
anticipation was better than what we
actually got which was kind of nothing
other than that clanking sound
yeah which sounded to me immediately
like the clanking sound of Tony Stark
making my first is yeah in the first
Iron Man movie sort of bringing it all
back to where it started but at the same
time
the fact that there was no scene gave
the movie a real feeling of final yeah
to it like it really is the end of the
road for the MCU as we've known it
mm-hmm I agree yeah I agree and I think
that it's it's really exciting to
picture Tony Stark in heaven making a
brand new Iron Man suit where as an
angel no it's that was such a symbolic
little sound effect and it was again
paying tribute to everything that's come
before but I also think that the fact
that it was an Iron Man sound effect
versus a Captain America one or a Thor
or whatever meant that you know it's
that moving forward that legacy that
that building noise what is that
building towards is that gonna be his
daughter Morgan start building our own
suit is that yeah I mean we might see
that in ten years time we might see that
right wow what do you think well I think
it's just the sound from Iron Man I want
to interpret it differently I want to do
like be interpreted is it just like
Gwyneth in a garage being like you know
what oh yeah yeah but again just like
the fact that we didn't get one yeah
it's sort of made not having one was
actually satisfying
I agree agree because it changed like we
expected to get and we didn't and we
just went oh
okay all right I'm okay with that you
know anything yeah I wasn't like tossing
my popcorn and being like we've just
been so conditioned to get one yeah
there's DMC you asked hey what if he
just sat and watched the credits for one
of these what if you just did that by
the way he appreciated all these credits
makes amazing credits is amazing
my greatest cast in a movie ever made
there is like it when you watch when you
watch the ending credits down and see
you movie is absolutely infinity war an
end game that's a planet the entire
population of the earth oh there's no
there's always like crazy ones - it's
like the rocky racoon squad and you're
like what the eighty fifth person build
was Bradley Cooper
like that's how good this cast is yeah
number ninety Vin Diesel like that's
about have to for people like us when
we're watching the credits somebody see
we see the names of like jim Starlin
yeah john for me did you know Dolby
theater is like panicking right now
being like please don't let this get
nominated because we can't fill this
ticket that's it that's by the way I'm
just gonna say this now that when Wayne
Avengers endgame gets nominated for much
of Oscars hopefully Best Picture cuz
again I'm not calling anything I'm not
saying it's a luck but when that happens
and the movie makes more than three
billion dollars worldwide and beats
avatar as the new highest-grossing movie
of all time that I am calling I think
that is going to happen Wow right if
every saint game will beat avatar sorry
James Cameron but you have your fun in
the Sun so what that will translate into
for next year's Oscars higher ratings
more people are going to watch next
year's Oscars because of adventures end
game along because of all the
nominations that that movie will get not
necessarily win but definitely get
nominated
well I have so many more unanswered
questions about a vendor's end games so
would you guys be willing to stick
around we'll do a little more yes yeah
in the meantime let everybody know where
they can find you you find me on the
internet at Hector is funny and follow
along with all the stuff that I'm doing
and check me out on El Rey nation
Thursday nights at 10:30 check your
local listings on El Rey Aubrey Network
you can follow me on twitter at
movie manse you can follow me on
instagram at movie manse and check out
my website where I review everything at
movie manse calm and I'm ash Carlson
come right back
unanswered questions it's coming